ん
うん
こんにちわっ
和美社長です本日はこちら湘南の方にちょっと旅行ついてな感じで遊びに来ているん
ですけども
今回こちらの湘南には山ネットで予約してちょっと
旅行に来ております僕つとこの湘南で旅行生らに一つどうしてもやりたいことがあり
まして
やはり人類の指である空を飛ぶことにちょっと挑戦してみたいと思ってますねこのそう
なん
海の近くに実際に空を飛ぶことができる場所があるということなのでちょっと実際にさ
せるの方に行ってみようと思います
me
ええええええ
can
ban
ame
me
って
んん
moon
入った
me
ni
goo
ウバすごかっ
いやー
キュッポンと結構多くは4ですよ
怖いですけど
景色はすごい良かったですよかったからちとかっ
思うん
ん
はいという意味で水体験が終わって中の方にしました
今回の旅をですねじゃらん net 皆さんご存知の通り山ネットで予約して旅してき
たんですけども
実はですねじゃらん net で予約することによってご満悦ポイント貯めてるんです
けども
ponta カードを知ってますよねこのポンタカードにですねじゃらん net で
ウェアとして旅をするとポイントがチョ無料
になりましたいやもうこれで僕4年前からずっと使ってる pot ガードなんです
けどあいつを食べてるポンタポイント旅するだけで止まるようにのってすごい国も今後
活用してみようかなと思っております愛と良いで僕今シャベルこちらの肉まん
唐揚げおにぎりなどもじゃらんネットとかで予約して貯まったポイントを使ってカブ
ことができますでこのコンビニで買ってことによってさらにコンタク
最もとなるので ponta ポイントで買ったものに ponta ポイントがつく
のですごい有効的な活用の仕方ができますポイントでポイントを食べるんだよ
今回ゾンビにでご飯買ったんですけどもこういう使いてない以外にも今た web を
使えばさー
使い方がありますあの僕先でポンという実際に何ポイントは確認したんですけれども
チェーンサブウェイポイント溜まっています簡単にポイントたまってます僕はアンネ
こうたくさん貯まったポイントのコントロールでいろんな使い方ができますという皆
さん是非本体ウルコンポイント杉田まるでコントライブでうまいこと利用していろんな
ことに使ってみてください
じゃあ